nice to see you again sir nice to see
you I'm gonna say that I'm now seeing
you more than some of my friends and
that is amazing I'm just throwing that
out there seeing you more than I see my
wife how's that there we go so he's
gonna talk right let me start by saying
how awesome you are in this movie thank
you that's a good place to start yeah
you're tremendous one of the things when
did you know that he wanted to shoot
with old cameras old lenses and what
were your thoughts on that it did
surprise me and I think I knew very
quickly when he told me how we were
gonna show basically I part of the story
is I saw the Witch and I really sought
him out I really went to him met him and
said I want to work with you and this is
the first thing that he presented to me
um yeah you that meeting was a smart
idea oh one of the other things I loved
about the film is the use of dialogue
from the era the the beautiful it was
unbelievable I love that I love the
language of this film you know it's very
evocative it's very juicy it's fun to
play and it's skillful in the respect
that it it accomplishes things that you
couldn't accomplish with more prosaic
diet dialogue more natural dialogue
completely in terms of the relationship
and how we interact robert was
mentioning to me earlier that one of the
things that really surprised him was how
much light had to be used to shoot with
these cameras how was that to work with
because it's you know so unusual in this
era to film with that kind of Lighting's
um yeah I noticed that but I had bigger
fish to fry it was so cold and so
miserable not the lights any light you
could give me was fine I was pretended
it was sunlight one of the things I
think you told me a while ago when I
talked to you you mentioned that this
was an incredibly challenging shoot yeah
but I had
shoot in the respect that it was good
team and yeah the weather was miserable
but it did his job I mean it's a it's a
character in the movie and it really
informed everything we did what was I
mean I rarely asked this but I am
curious this this is such a unique
filmmaking process and with the dialogue
and everything what was your when did
you finally see the movie and what was
your reaction finally taking it all in
I saw it when you know probably right
before it first showed that can just so
I could speak about it and then I saw it
it came as well my memory usually when
you see a movie the associations of
making the movie are so strong you can't
see it at all this was interesting
because there's not coverage the shots
are very well designed very specific we
didn't shoot a lot you know there
weren't a lot of editing possibilities
Louise Ford did a beautiful job of
editing I'm not taking anything away
from her she did some beautiful things
but basically the film looked like I
thought it would and also was a document
of the experience we went through it
felt like the shooting of it the only
thing that you missed was you had some
sense of it but the bone-chilling cold
and the wetness but you even had the
sense of that sometimes I got that my
last question for you there are three
things I want to ask you about and okay
T's I am so excited for Wes Anderson's
French dispatch good yeah I am over the
moon for del Toro's nightmare alley and
it's rumored that you're gonna work with
Robert again on Northman looks like it
right so my question is what have you
teased about these three things um first
one is Wes Wes fantastic we shot in the
South of France
to be fair it's a huge cast and I don't
know what to say about it except for the
truth is I play you know basically a
cameo in that but very beautiful cameo
we hope Guillermo
I'm very excited about this project it's
a very juicy project a good role we
shoot that
you know in March we started March and
yeah Rob Baker is this was such a
beautiful experience I told you I saw
them out after the witch so yeah I'll be
working with them again but I can't say
much about it I completely understand
thank you so much for your time and
congrats on this you're thinking